here are the people who are owed an
apology from the Democrats from the
media and from the rabid never Trump
errs tonight first the President himself
I don't need the mullah report to know
he's a traitor I have a TV
there's outright treason this is nothing
short of treasonous because it is a
betrayal of the nation President Trump
could be indicted and possibly face jail
time this is a potentially more
dangerous situation than Watergate these
destructive and defamatory allegations
were based on erroneous reporting
anonymous sources leaks and whispers
gossip but now with the release of the
mother report we find that it was all
false the Trump family is also owed an
apology when you get involved with you
know the actions of his children
including his daughter and son-in-law
we're getting closer to criminal
activities Ivanka and Don Jr are now
fully implicated in the selling of
American democracy for the Trump family
game what you'll see is a man who wants
to share the inner workings of the Trump
crime family none of it was true
attorney general Barr certainly deserves
an apology he won't get his reputation
back it's shot the Attorney General of
the United States of America has been
corrupted he's lost the credibility of
the American people all of them no words
for their calumny their lies and their
false accusations are they really paying
you enough to say that stuff guys and to
those who branded the prime time host on
this network as state news for daring to
tell the truth not just our truth but
the truth you owe us an apology Fox News
will be an incredible asset to the
president that echo chamber is going to
announce this as a vindication we talked
about this
door there's also of course the echo
chamber right we know Hannity and the
president speak all the time
president Trump sort of lives in an echo
chamber we know that he sort of
obsessively watches cable news he really
focuses on what you know Fox News is
saying what his state study for him is
his echo chamber of Fox News no wonder
they were so angry today
it was sedition treason now it's Fox it
finally the American people are owed an
apology
your precious tax dollars were spent and
the country's focus diverted to
investigate a president who was innocent
from the outset based on a dossier
that was fake and that was paid for by
the Clinton campaign other networks and
print media journalists tricked viewers
and readers into thinking their
president was a Russian stooge it was
all false this was pure and simple an
effort to undermine the results of the
presidential election and manipulate
public opinion every effort should be
made to investigate the origins and
motivations of this Muller investigation
and in the coming hour we will separate
from you legal fact from fiction in the
Muller report we'll unpack the political
ramifications and tell you where we go
from here
and it just moments we'll be joined by
president Trump's attorney Rudy Giuliani
now but first before we dive in in our
expert panel analysis I want to give you
my takeaways from the Muller report and
a few things that you need to keep in
mind number one the president and his
team they went above and beyond in their
transparency in dealing with a special
counsels office this openness in and of
itself cuts against any suggestions you
might be hearing on the other cables
about obstruction of justice
my friends if Trump wanted to obstruct
justice he wouldn't have waived
executive privilege now if you don't
know what that is it's the doctrine
which would have shielded much of the
president's internal communications from
investigators
and from the public but he didn't do
that in fact I would argue remember I
was a former criminal defense lawyer
myself clerk at the court I would argue
that the president's team may have went
have gone overboard in giving Muller too
much information but anyway this
demonstrates the president's supreme
confidence in his own innocence from the
very beginning he had nothing to hide
and by the way the transparency even
extended to the release of the report
itself remember the American people are
getting much more than is required by
law and Bill Barr he didn't have to do
this synopsis of the report he didn't
have to answer press questions this
morning he didn't even have to release
the report to the public or to Congress
his only obligation was to report his
findings to Congress that's it number
two the media coverage of this Russian
collusion coordination conspiracy story
was an epic failure from beginning to
well right about now now remember the
Trump Tower meeting in June of 2016 the
meeting at Trump Tower and all the lies
to cover up that meeting that to me is
direct evidence all of this talk about a
second meeting yeah is truly damning
Trump Tower meeting which indeed was
convened for the purpose of collusion
all false it turns out that Muller found
there was no evidence that President
Trump had any advanced knowledge of the
Trump Tower meeting or was involved in
it in any way
now they also did not find by the way
that Donald Trump jr. or any participant
in the meeting violated any law instead
the report said quote the government
does not have strong evidence of
surreptitious behavior or efforts at
concealment at the term of the June 9th
meeting well the story turned out to be
a complete and total farce and dud
and then oh yeah by the way Carter page
he worked for the Trump campaign as a
foreign policy advisor at least in his
name was on an advisory list for eight
months the FBI though got a FISA warrant
to surveil page citing that fake dossier
funded by trumps opponent Carter page
was conspiring with Russia to in ways
that that were nefarious he should have
been surveilled it would not have been
very difficult for the FBI to convince a
judge that there was probable cause to
believe that Carter page was acting as
an agent of a foreign power
but in the end Muller writes on page 95
that his team quote did not establish
that page coordinated with the Russian
government and its efforts to interfere
with the 2016 presidential election
remember there were four FISA warrants
all of them incomplete
another abuse of power by the Obama FBI
and the rest of the deep State number
three for all of that all that we
already talked about the mother report
is really kind of just an invitation
when you read it especially towards the
end for the House of Representatives to
run the ball to the impeachment
goal-line the resistant media and some
left-wing Dems are now hanging their
impeachment hopes now there's no
collusion on the fact that Muller did
not specifically exonerate Trump on
obstruction of justice today they were
grasping at more straws and making a lot
of trumps reaction to the appointment of
the Special Counsel when he said oh my
god this is terrible this is the end of
my presidency I'm blind
the press claims that's the reaction of
a guilty man this is the end of my
presidency
I'm effed he slumped back in his chair
according to the report and said oh my
god this is terrible this is the end of
my presidency I'm f what is laid out
here
rats crazy s
asked all this stuff in there is that
not enough
but when Trump said it was the end of my
presidency it was because he believed he
was a man unfairly accused and rightly
he was enraged over the fact that his
entire agenda would be stymied and his
presidency mired in years of
investigation he understood that from
the very beginning I'll blame him for
being that mad it certainly isn't any
evidence of an intent to obstruct anyone
who says differently should either have
his law license revoked or frankly not
be commenting on these matters on
television go do something else but the
left is say you're claiming that
Muller's findings convict Trump of
obstruction even though Muller stated
that he could not draw such a conclusion
here's what he says on page 8 of volume
2 quote unlike cases in which a subject
engages an obstruction of justice to
cover up a crime the evidence we
obtained did not establish that the
president was involved in an underlying
crime related to Russian election
interference
although the obstruction statutes do not
require proof of such a crime the
absence of the evidence affects the
analysis of the president's intent and
requires consideration of other possible
motives for his conduct judgments about
the nature of the president's motives
during each phase would be informed by
the totality of the evidence and bar and
the legal team at DOJ did examine the
totality of evidence and even use
Muller's legal framework to analyze his
findings on obstruction after two years
and thirty million dollars taxpayer
money the Democrats will not accept the
Justice Department's findings bars
findings and they plan to relitigate the
entire drama one way or another they're
gonna try to do it from now until 2020
but what they should be investigating is
how this first began and who was
responsible what their motives were the
surveillance of innocent Americans
the deception in the FISA Court
applications the illegal leaking of
government documents and information and
the entire Muller probe were never about
holding a president accountable the
purpose was to destroy Trump and his
agenda in order to regain political
power